What does the future hold
maybe I can Pokemon this
Welcome back everyone this will be my full Rick
and Morty Season 6 Episode 5 video there's a whole
bunch Easter eggs and references so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel
I'm doing videos for all the episodes be sure to
subscribe to get them and careful for spoilers
from the episode if you haven't seen it yet
we'll start at the beginning and just work our
way through shot by shot talking about Easter
Eggs and WTF moments as we go along the actual
episode title is final desmithation which is a
reference to the Final Destination movie series
which are all about characters learning about
their Des their final Fates and trying to avoid
them but failing to do so like they usually wind
up meeting their Fates in ironic twists in this
episode is all about Rick and Jerry trying to
stop a company from controlling fate using the
chaos alien and its special fortune cookies
that it creates the episode is also basically
like another Rick and Jerry episode it felt like
a pretty small episode compared to some of the
others just because it mostly took place inside
this goop facility that they were parroting it
was a big Gwyneth Paltrow goop parody candle it's
it's just for you it smells like my taint and it's
gonna you're too much the writer said that they
intended for it to be similar to previous Rick
and Jerry episodes where during the course of the
episode they kind of become closer as friends but
by the end also kind of not like they treat it
like they're not friends even though they do
kind of become closer like we're getting pissed
off at the end because all he had to do to stay
Invincible for the rest of his life was to not
make any more friends for the rest of his life
but the sheer fact that he got pissed off means
that he and Jerry actually did become friends
otherwise his fortune would still be unresolved
and he would still be Invincible the family's
clowned on him a whole bunch this season about
that too the whole idea that he really does care
about them but he's unwilling to admit it
the way they explain fate in the episode is
that Rick says that it's like a probability field
except at the center is everything that is known
pulling everything that's unknown towards it so
for instance when Jerry's Fortune is unresolved
in the episode The Closer that his mother gets to
him in proximity the more probable it becomes that
he will eventually get with her so that's why it
just starts out with a couple texts but then as
she gets closer more and more things happen and
they get closer and closer and closer towards the
very end of the episode until Rick saves him the
actual opening scene takes place with the family
at Panda Express making a bunch of cultural jokes
about how Panda Express is like the least Chinese
Chinese restaurant you could go to in America it
also shows you that the family has been going to
Chinese restaurants eating fortune cookies for
a long time now Rick said later that the company
had been using this fortune cookie alien for
the past 20 years meaning that the family has
probably had their Fates altered a couple times
because of fortune cookies previously they make
a bunch of tick tock Jokes which is mostly like
old people making fun of young people for doing
silly things on Tick Tock like Tick Tock is
primarily a platform used by the youngest
generation currently like the whole joke with the
taxi song that the kids don't really understand
why it's cool they just think that it sounds
good but Rick reveals later in the episode that
one of his favorite songs on this playlist is
Angela's theme from Taxi so like because he's
old he actually watched the TV show and likes the
song in the correct context but in the new context
the kids are just using it because it sounds
good they don't really understand what it means
it's also a bit of a call back to Summer's Die
Hard episode when she hadn't seen the movie so
she didn't understand what it actually meant and
she just kind of made up the meaning as she went
along like she just kept repeating the phrase Die
Hard Die Hard until the end of the episode when
she actually did learn what it meant because
she read the story they said that the whole
post-credit scene joke with the bit about Jerry
being confused by the way they put animal food in
Gumball looking machines in the zoo they even have
what almost seems like a fourth wall break from
Morty when he acknowledges the joke that they're
making with the fake commercial at the zoo about
them being in a human zoo in zebras being the
ones who are really in control like we're the
ones that are in the zoo also side note Jerry
also reveals that he gets diarrhea every time
they go to water parks we'll see if they pay that
off in a future episode and the family actually
goes to a water park one of the early jokes here
about the fortune cookies is that most of them
are generic and repeated like all fortune cookies
are kind of like this later the old man explains
that that's actually part of a larger fortune that
the Fortune 500 company got to dilute the market
with a bunch of fake fortunes so that the real
fortune became more potent they introduced the
whole joke about Jerry doing it with his mother
which the old man also explains was part of his
Cry for Help which they pay off by saying that he
created a bunch of different types of Fortunes in
an attempt to try and get people to come help him
the first batch of Fortunes were more literal the
consequence being that people would break their
legs if they didn't come investigate this company
implying that a bunch of people broke their legs
the next one with the fortune that said that a
virus was shut down the world is actually a joke
about the virus in real life shutting everything
down with the lockdowns during 2020 and because
no one came to help him it's implying that the
fortune cookies were responsible for the big
virus in 2020 then he said his last attempt
was to create a bunch of ones that said people
would do it with their mothers and the joke is
that Jerry's the only person who actually showed
up meaning that a bunch of other people actually
got with their mothers which is a big Oedipus joke
complex because later they also turn it into a
Morty thing when he talks about dressing as Morty
because Beth is his wife implying that Morty might
also want to get with Beth deep down inside why
are you dressed like Morty because Morty's mom is
Beth I'm not unpacking that this is also the first
episode to bring back Jerry's mother since season
one like we haven't seen her in a long time but if
you remember one of the jokes of that episode was
that she had a secret lover on the side and her
husband Jerry's biological father would sit in
the closet and watch them while he was dressed up
as superheroes so Jerry already comes from a very
spicy family he makes another sleepy Gary Total
Recall reference to season two when he says that
his gag reflex has been mixed up because of his
time with sleepy Gary that means exactly what you
think it means he got down and dirty with sleepy
Gary big time but if you remember we saw in the
previous episode that he actually was getting with
other versions of himself just like Beth was so we
already knew that Jerry was bi I think of that one
as like the Loki episode because it's them getting
with other versions of themselves Beth asking him
not to tell summer is also her not wanting to give
summer another eating disorder like summer already
has a whole bunch of stuff going on with her whole
bunch of problems but I don't think she actually
has an eating disorder right now Rick mentions The
X-Files they reveal Summer's Tick Tock account is
summer song 69 which is a 69 DTF joke like summer
is super horny but is also a reference to the song
She's sang with a Tinkles character also from the
sleepy time Gary episode total Rick all there were
a couple references to that episode during this
one this screen to the phone is from Morty's phone
so we find out he's got the other family members
on it of course he's got Noob noobs number still
Brent is a person in real life who works on the
animation crew he's got Mr Poopy butthole he's got
April which I think is meant to be a call back to
the April Fool's joke which was season 3 episode
1. they aired it on April Fool's Day the Justin
person is Justin Roiland so like the joke is is
that he actually calls Justin Roiland in real
life and the whole idea that Justin is the actual
voice of the Morty character the Wilder person is
a reference to Wilder Reese who's another crew
member working on the series so the joke here is
kind of like Morty calling the people who actually
make Rick and Morty episodes controlling the story
there are also a couple fourth wall breaks from
Rick in the episode where he acknowledges them
being inside a television episode but he's known
that he's been inside a television show for a
long time now the whole thing is going on here
with the family clowning on Jerry they said that
they wanted Rick to feel like Jerry deserved his
help because he didn't like the idea of the family
forcing him to do something he didn't want to do
and it's just an example of Rick actually being
Jerry's friend without totally admitting it but
once he does this he does find out that something
really weird is going on and it turns into the
actual plot of the episode you also notice when
Rick is walking past them with the towels in his
hand that's just paying off the joke about him
having to do his own laundry finally because he
doesn't have portals to steal fresh clothes from
other versions of himself you know the space
Beth comes back again which is a big surprise
I wasn't expecting her back for a while I guess
they weren't kidding when they said that she'd
be coming back a lot this season also space Beth
makes it sound like she visits zoos in outer space
for fun like she says the Earth version of the zoo
as if she goes to other zoos that are not on Earth
his probability detector looks a lot like the
detector from Ghostbusters but he's also used this
one in the series before too Rick also reveals
that it's equally possible for him to become both
a dolphin or a balloon version of himself so we'll
see if they pay that off in a future episode where
we see a balloon Rick in a dolphin Rick he also
implies that he hates Panda Express because he's
never said to another human being that he wants to
go to a Panda Express they pay off the Taxi theme
song Joke when they reveal that his favorite
song on his playlist is Angela's theme from
the taxi show like I said the whole joke with the
kids tick tock song is that they hadn't actually
seen the series so they didn't know the song in
its original context is like Rick getting mad at
the kids for not appreciating the songs of the way
that he thinks that they're supposed to appreciate
it the whole joke with Rick and the drug dealers
hear him being cool with them is another joke
about his ongoing feud with the Earth government
and the Earth president he hates both of them so
he doesn't mind if anyone does anything illegal
he breaks the fourth wall again when he references
himself being inside a television episode story
he's done this before like I said he's known that
he's been a fictional character for a long time
now I'm not sure if the guns he's using here are
specific references to anything usually his guns
on the show like his weapons are references to
video game weapons so if you think you recognize
them just write Below in the comments the big bad
in the episode is meant to be big Gwyneth Paltrow
goop reference her name in the episode is genith
padro chant the word play with that last little
part of her name is exactly what you think it is
her headquarters building here is meant to be
sort of like a fortune cookie reference but I
also think it's kind of meant to be a reference to
the Sailor Moon Millennium Castle because of the
big Sailor Moon reference after this Rick makes a
big Sailor Moon magical girl transformation joke
about how he saves money by them using the Sailor
Moon effect to change their clothes multiple times
which itself is a reference to real life when
animation companies reuse animation in episodes
to save money like this isn't just an anime joke
regular Western cartoons are famous for reusing
animation to save money and the whole idea in
previous seasons is that one of the reasons why
Rick and Morty Seasons took so long to come out
is because the animation on Rick and Morty is so
much more complex than other series they reuse far
less of it than other cartoons do and recently Dan
Harmon has basically said oh we won't have big
breaks anymore we've worked out a lot of those
kings so in the episode when Rick says Ah look
at all the money we're saving it's also another
joke about how quickly they're getting Seasons
out one year after the other without huge breaks
anymore he makes a Sesame Street Cookie Monster
joke The Fortune 500 logos on everything is just
a reference to the actual real-life Fortune 500
Index with the 500 most valuable companies any
given moment when Rick starts showing off his
enhancements like all the stuff that he's got
inside his body that's Meant To Be An Inspector
Gadget reference which he's made previously on
the series but the other joke here is that he's
got really high-tech weapons and low-tech weapons
and some Magic based weapons too like one of them
is just a broken bottle the other one is a voodoo
doll when he says I have fundara that's a big
Thundercats reference another 80s cartoon most of
the fortunes that they walk past on the index and
the walls here are just like the generic fortunes
but one of them says you like Chinese food which
feels like one of the real fortunes like it's
trying to force people to enjoy Chinese food even
though in real life I actually do like Chinese
food like Chinese food is actually pretty good
when they're getting on the elevator one of these
fortunes also says you'll receive help in your
time of need which is basically exactly what's
happening to Jerry in this episode Rick is helping
him in his time of need then I think the joke here
with a goop company and all the celebrities trying
to pay money to get to higher tiers and greater
levels of understanding within the organization
is also more of a Scientology joke on top of all
the goop jokes they imply Jeff Bezos Bill Gates
a bunch of other Prime Ministers around the world
and Billy Zane are part of it for some reason like
all the richest most powerful people in the world
are buying into this company because a lot of
really powerful people are scientologists in real
life the whole joke about her eating Ramen out of
a toilet in her parents garage 15 years ago is in
real life Gwyneth Paltrow's acting career kind of
stalled out in the early 2000s about 15 years ago
also in real life her father is insanely wealthy
like she comes from this really wealthy family
basically growing up a princess so that's one of
the reasons why they're clowning on her so hard in
the episode list is a rich person who got even
richer with her goop company Rick also reveals
that he's had sex with Jerry's mom already then I
think this is the first time that we've actually
seen this particular alien on Rick and Morty but
he calls it a ligurian which eats chaos but it has
a digestive disorder order which is what they're
using to create the fortune cookies and these
fortunes to influence people's faiths he also
breaks the fourth wall again to tell everyone
that they've been eating alien poop every time
they eat fortune cookies and like I said Rick
says that they've been using this alien for the
past 20 years meaning that the family who's eating
Chinese food in fortune cookies in the past 20
years many times have probably had their Fates
influenced multiple times in their past when he
pulls up the generic fortunes here Happy Feet
and people like me are actually names of movies
Rick makes another Nintendo reference when he
says portable VR headset that's more of a virtual
boy reference but it's also part of a long-running
Nintendo thing that Justin Roiland Works into Rick
and Morty episodes because he is a huge Nintendo
fan in real life so anytime Rick rants about
Nintendo in episodes that's usually Justin Royal
and working that into episodes for example another
callback to that same Total Recall episode that's
where he did his more famous Nintendo rant that
particular reference they said was actually from
real life because Justin Roiland like literally
came into the Rick and Morty writers room when
they were working on that episode and Rick's
rant is exactly word for word the rant that
Justin Roiland burst into the room talking about
that particular day the old man sounds like he
was actually voiced by Alex Hirsch who does a
lot of voice over cameos on the DL on animated
series but usually he gets credits for that and I
couldn't find his name in the credits Rick kind of
breaks the fourth wall again when he references
how on the nose the old man character is inside
this particular story when he says the character
is Arch what he means is extremely obvious or
forced reference to something the whole joke about
him wanting to get married to the animal I think
it's just meant to be a reference to the Margaret
Howe dolphin joke later in the episode she was a
conservationist that tried to teach Dolphins how
to speak in one of the dolphins that she raised
was famously super horny so at the time Hustler
magazine published a story joking about that so
her getting with the dolphin is just a reference
to that the curvy bullets I think are meant to
be a reference to The Wanted movie he makes a
Pokemon reference when he talks about using the
fire person against the water person and all their
powers are meant to be ironic like he pulls water
from a person's body killing him the other guys
body sticks to walls but his internal organs do
not so they get sucked out the person who can't be
killed can still feel all the pain when Rick eats
all the random fortunes one of them reveals that
he's got a secret crush who will call him at some
point so keep an eye out for anybody that calls
Rick in future episodes the make a new friend
Fortune is a reference to the unresolved fortune
that Jerry resolves at the end of the episode like
at this moment he becomes Invincible this guy
is a Grimlock Transformers Dinobot reference
and even though this is just kind of like a
funny moment I love that this guy turns into
a sentient teleprompter and his reaction turns
into the script on the screen they explain the
Gwyneth Paltrow characters unresolved Fortune is
that she'll become the world's most successful
businesswoman the bigger joke is that that would
never happen like her Lifestyle brand would never
be the world's most successful company so she
just basically becomes Invincible for the rest
of her life until Rick uses his hacking skills to
make her company the most successful company on
paper but then taking it right back making her
company worthless when she transforms into the
monster here this is a naked era reference and
when he sits dead center on the alignment chart
that means he's true neutral as in he's just as
likely to do bad things as good things he's just
as likely to be chaotic as he is a lawful ordered
he makes a reference to Leonardo DiCaprio being
dead inside ever since he won an Oscar for the
Revenant several years ago and then Rick using
his last remaining fortune to save Jerry further
implies that they are friends resolving his other
fortune to keep his invincibility in the end
the episode playing the same Angela's theme
taxi song from earlier the actual post-credit
scene like I said is just them paying off the
joke about people eating zebra food but turning
it into a larger thing like revealing that they
are secretly inside a zebra zoo like they're Human
animals inside a zoo and the zebras are the ones
who are really in control also the person in the
Hat in the background here seems like he's been
in previous episodes I can't remember which crew
member this is a reference to I think it's meant
to be a reference to someone specifically if
you think you know who it is just write below
in the comments if you spotted any other Easter
eggs and references in the episode that I didn't
talk about in the video just write down below in
the comments in my full Rick and Morty episode 6
video we'll post next week after they release it
there's a whole bunch of big stuff coming this
week make sure to enable alerts for my channel so
you don't miss it everyone click here for my House
of the Dragon Episode 8 video and click it for my
brand new black panther wakanda forever trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!